[Music]
hello there everyone it is an absolute
privilege and an honor for us to be
featuring Tony Robbins on the Tony
Robbins podcast
thanks for the invite ladies
hi sweetheart
[Music]
on today's session I'm joining for the
very beginning again these two ladies
are going to take you on the journey but
you know it's February and Valentine's
Day is coming up right around the time
we're filming this or shooting this I
should say and you know there's
chocolates everywhere and the idea of
romance being promoted and a lot of it
just feels false and second you know
just artificial it's not authentic I
think a lot of people are really jaded
about what love is because they've had
love and now they associate pain to love
and it's not pain that the love is not
the pain it's the loss of love that
people fear and so I thought maybe we
could have a little conversation here
with me in the beginning and you guys
can take over about what really is love
and it's incredibly powerful force to
shape us because there's nothing on
Earth the more powerful nothing will
take someone to their knees quicker I
don't care the strongest Warrior on
Earth man or woman than the loss of love
nothing lifts you higher than love when
when you're totally in love what's wrong
with life nothing you know you don't
need money you don't need back or
anything you'll figure that stuff out
because love is that fuel I think it's
so important that for people to think
about that it is how we're wired babies
that aren't physically loved that aren't
held don't have kinesthetic love develop
something called failure to thrive
syndrome and they can die love is our
evolutionary Advantage you know many
species are born and you know the baby
is the parents aren't there you know
it's an egg that hatches and so the
evolutionary Advantage is they've got
horns or they've got teeth or they got
camouflage but if a human baby's left
alone in the forest no one's there it's
going to die our Evolution Advantage is
that we fall in love which means we will
put someone else's needs ahead of our
own and I think that's critical and that
doesn't have to just be intimate love
you know in the form of physical
intimacy it can be the love of chosen
family it can certainly be the love of
family and we've certainly experienced
the whole explosion of that with this
Modern Family we have here and with our
our daughter who's just shy of two years
two years old now it's been an explosion
of Love wouldn't you say it certainly
has but you're an explosion
you are so such a lover to all you know
for those of you who've maybe ever had
proximity or went to an event or
attended one of our programs uh you know
what people always say is that if
there's 10 000 people I felt like Tony
was speaking directly to me and they
might be like way at the back of the
stadium and that's love love penetrates
or permeates is more accurately space
and time and it's that intimacy of one
offering their heart and you do that so
generously so abundantly toned I mean
every day day and no it is who you are
flows out of you uh you're such a a
beautiful vessel of love in in a form
that's unexpected you know a lot of
people look at you this big you know
this big physical stature and not know
actually the the real tenderness and
sincerity
um that expresses as as your isness of
who you are as well well my my mission
is to have the people feel loved and
cared for sometimes I love this too
strong they don't believe it but when
you're up there sweating for 12 straight
hours the third day and people get
converted and they start going this guy
really means it
um but you know I just this just got
back from the JP Morgan uh conference
and what I was really touched by in that
environment was uh Jamie Diamond who's
the you know the CEO of that bank JP
Morgan uh the end of this whole talk and
the the thing that permeated the room
was this feeling of kindness and love
that that's the missing ingredient in
our world and to even have the bankers
say that and then of course Mary Callen
Airedale some of you read my books on
finance and she's probably one of the
most influential women in all Finance
managers I don't know four or five
trillion dollars now in business and you
see she created an environment where
everybody felt nurtured cared for loved
looked out for but the most successful
leaders that I know are heart-driven
leaders I mean what makes you a leader
is you care about something more than
yourself you care about something
whether it's your family your kids or
your community there's something you
love that's where energy comes from
that's what changes life so I just I
hope that we all know what love is we
all know we can't live without it but
we've all had disappointments in pain
and I hope that those out there will
reconsider that love could be something
you could open yourself to and the first
steps of just kindness and just caring
and just warmth and love that's outside
an intimate relationship and if you can
find that outside the relationship it
can also lead to the intimacy that so
many people are craving I know I've
mentioned this before but it always
strikes me
dear friends and
at by the the expression of how you care
for them how you love them it's very
demonstrative that happens on stage that
happens at home you are that you are
that and you know
it definitely takes one to no one it's
been 24 years since I hooked up with you
my weirdo that's true my wife is the
weirdest human I love I love by the way
she's the most weird wasn't on my list
but it's one of the great gifts but the
weirdness is touch with humor and love
everything you do is love you're the
love to so many people you love to this
whole family or the love to all the
people in our companies I mean you just
you exude it in every way sweetheart and
that's why I'm so excited that you guys
have kind of commented the podcast here
because so few people get to know what I
get to know which is you and Mary
together is just the love that you are
and what all the gifts you guys have to
share the insights you have to share and
so I'm I'm grateful to drop into the
Tony Robbins podcast with you but what I
love is what comes out between the two
Because unless people are part of our
Platinum partnership with things like
that where they all get to know you very
well and you teach with me a lot of
people don't get to see that so true I'm
grateful that people get your
perspective I want to hear your
perspective on what is love and what
drives love from your perspective you
know coming into this conversation Mary
and I were talking and
I was saying that I really look at love
as an inside out experience and I think
that sometimes that's not that it can't
come external in as well it flows both
ways like all of life there's an ebb and
flow like an ocean but I think sometimes
it's imbalanced in our society of the
expectation that love would be coming
from the outside uh rather than I am a
love I am love you know I don't mean I
me I mean we are born as love I think
that is the most clear takeaway uh being
parents at this stage and watching our
daughter and watching this Essence just
flow out of her as her there's no doing
in that there's no thought in that it is
it is it emanates it resonates and uh
love that Essence and watching her uh
just shine I think is so extraordinary
and reminds me of the fact that it it is
inside of us it's in every one of us
it's our nature when we get out of our
own human way or we you you know drop
the conditionings or The Impressions
that a wireless in in a way that you
know innocently makes us expect that I
want you know I want love and if you
love me you know you'll do this it's
it's we instantly can put all these
demands on love which of course you know
creates a restriction and and doesn't
allow love to flow and so I think the
intent of this or what we were speaking
on mayor and I walking into this was
just that love is indeed everywhere and
coming into this month of of uh you know
of uh where are we Valentine's Day
February uh and and it's beautiful
because it's focused on romantic love
but if you look at how we live our life
and the beauty of our life and we love
each other so deeply and dearly I think
what's gorgeous about it is that it's
more beautiful because of this
extraordinary extended family that we
have Mary being one of them yes you've
brought more Beauty to our life because
of the sharing and and it magnifies life
having our daughter magnified love
bringing Billy Becker masterco or Diana
all these beautiful souls where my mommy
and daddy comes and and I think that's
the beautiful gift that when we're
walking this Human Experience and maybe
you are if you're you know listening to
this right now your you know mind can
have this narrative yeah but I I want
the one and I think sometimes you know
we can miss the love that's in front of
us when we're wanting that or expecting
that or Desiring it not to say that you
can't have that desire you know to fall
in love because you know but love just a
lot of times looks different this
constellation looks different than I
ever imagined the sharing in the
experience of of being a parent and I
think sharing is a basis of love as well
you know no question and and but yet as
we share
it it grows it it grows and and and
we're in a culture these days where it's
mine you know it's it's mine there's
this gathering for oneself and and it's
so beautiful to share in the gifts that
you know God has blessed us with and the
biggest mistake I think with love is
think thinking that love is something
you go get or relationship is where you
go get love when I think a relationship
is where you go to give love we all have
practiced that that's why there's more
there's never less for anybody and I
think the ultimate test in a
relationship whether it be a deep
friendship or anything else is you know
what do you want to give for this when
you're in love with somebody you give
anything you're lit up by what you give
you're not saying what am I getting the
minute you start measuring what are you
getting now it's it's a trade it's a
horse trade it doesn't love anymore it's
an exchange there's nothing wrong with
an exchange
um you can do that in business but even
the most successful business people that
I know they love their clients they they
they fall in love with their client not
their product or service yes or another
way of looking at seeing our daughter
who you you know we we want to make sure
she understood sign language before she
could speak so a lot of frustrations
with children is they're trying to
communicate but no one understands so
now she speaks obviously I think putting
a lot of words together but she'll go to
like her music class or something and
you guys know she sits there rubs her
heart which means you know please then
she'll say please put her answer she
wants to hug every kid's like smacking
her aside get away from me doesn't stop
her she keeps coming like a lovebug and
why is that because that's all she's
seen
pleases us everybody hugs kisses loves
acknowledges and love is also how you
express it a relationship is often the
sum of communications you have you know
Dr gottman Who's probably the greatest
expert in the world on intimate
relationship love in terms of
sustainability he has a 90 was it 91
success rate and watching a couple talk
for 15 minutes and saying whether or not
they'll be divorced within five years
and the reason is there are certain ways
of communicating that turn people off
when you roll your eyes to your partner
when you you know you're non-responsive
you look somewhere else when they're
communicating to you when you you know
are telling your partner what to do when
you're trying to control them there's
certain issues that just kill the
experience of love no one wants to be
controlled but I think you the way to
look at the love in your life is say how
can I expand at the most basic level the
caring and kindness I have for the
people around me I know that some
Studies have done with kids that are
very violent and there was a group in
Texas that I worked with years ago
probably 25 years ago and it was in this
high school and they got these kids to
care for animals and they learn to care
and love an animal and then it started
transferring to humans maybe you don't
have what you want yet or you're in a
relationship that doesn't feel like
there's a lot of intimacy or closeness
maybe it's time to get closer to some of
your friends and build the muscle up so
to speak you know honey you're
unbelievable at self-love I think it's
because of your connection to God and
your way of looking at life but you like
you give yourself a kiss you say bless
me not excuse me when you sneeze
but it's true but it's so innocent and
so true there's no ego to it it's not
about you so walk into a wall and then
be like oh I'm sorry yeah she says I'm
sorry to her body and kisses it and so
forth now I'm not made that way but I
want to hear your and I think it'd be
great to hear the share of of your view
of self-love because it has a negative
frame for a lot of people and other
people say well I can't love others
because I don't love myself I don't know
I don't know if that's that absolute
where do you where does yourself love
come from and I mean that in the high
yes regard because it's one of the
things that inspires me and Mary does it
not absolutely you know it's just it's
beautiful because it's so pure it's not
it's it's not there's no affectation to
it it's not positioning it's just total
sincere love towards your own body and
spirit there's a kindness to yourself
that most people don't have for
themselves without that tinge that is in
media today of like I just need to love
myself yeah no I'm not talking about
that crap oh my gosh there's nothing
else I'm saying no limitation there's no
positioning there's no virtue signaling
it's just really real
well I'm asking myself as I'm listening
to you guys talking right now I think I
really have the lens or the filter that
life is a miracle and I feel that our
bodies the fact that I'm alive blows my
mind uh and I know that sounds just
because you hung out with me for the
last
24 years I'm serious dragging around the
planet and I don't know if it's because
you know we've had different health
challenges and and so forth come to the
surface that all of a sudden uh has a
lens that I feel even more preciousness
or an awakeness to the to the Miracle of
Life but I really have a sense like wow
this body of mine like it it serves me
so well it supports me every day that
makes me grateful it makes me want to
take care of her and by the way I did
not always have that filter I did not
always have that lens you know I think
it happened or the shift happened coming
into my early 40s and uh I would I was
I've always been an extender yeah I've
always been a love and and looking after
supporting people in my life but but I I
missed myself for so many years that's
the truth Tome I can't say I've always
been this way I think it's evolved
through life through pain through having
challenges with my health and
recognizing that oh my gosh I would do
this for anybody a a beloved friend of
mine my my mama you know my our child
you anything and yet why wouldn't I
offer that to myself yes and I if I as
I'm as I'm you know just observing my
own thoughts I think that really came
from
at a stage of you know my health being
compromised yes and experiencing the
physicality of that the reality of that
and it really woke me up it woke me up
that Holy flip this life this moment
this body is a gift and uh I fell in
love with serving her I know that sounds
crazy but like I'll get out of the
shower and I'll be like all right
sweetheart here we go you know and and
I'll I'll think about and I many times
I'll walk down the stairs and it's like
okay you know how can I bless myself and
so I'll ask myself and then it's like
how can I bless myself and it's like oh
you know what a lemon water or it'll
make me tune in or causes me to tune in
and recognize that gosh you know I
haven't drank a water recently or you
know I'm hungry or do you know what I'll
just step outside for a minute because
it feels good even if I'm going into a
meeting even if I have a call uh Mary
you did it so beautifully today you were
like you know I actually thought it was
so lovely you were you were like you
know I'm feeling chilled I just want to
go outside and stand on the Seawall for
two minutes and come back in here and
then we'll get ready for the recording
yeah but I loved that for you I
recognized that act for yourself it was
being true to yourself and then when we
do that we have more to give I remember
I'm gonna tell the story just because
it's coming through me right now but I
remember when we were going to Abu Dhabi
and and I'm creating a context of this
because another way I think to support
ourselves is being sincere and true
about uh maybe a yes or a no for
ourselves and uh we were going there for
our Platinum partnership event and
um I think it was maybe like the day
before we were landing and you had were
invited to go to dinner
the Crown Prince yeah
and and you know I started to feel
stressed and I was like why am I feeling
stressed because the truth was it felt
insincere for me for my body and my
being if I was landing on the time zone
to go to this dinner and so you know
before if I was to say no it would have
come up come out clunky maybe I would
have said no if I was frustrated I would
have said no if I was angry but you know
in that moment I recognized that honey I
love you this feels insincere for me if
it's meaningful for you I'll go but if
it's not it would be really meaningful
for me to see of course so of course I
cancel the meeting with the Crown Prince
by calling his people and they said you
really don't want to do this because it
would be seen as a slight in our culture
and that was certainly not where we're
coming from so Mary accompanied me we
went to the dinner luckily tone has a
jvb team beloved and I was like well go
I slept on the plane and I thought it
was so beautiful Mary because I remember
I took Joy because you were like what on
God's green earth am I gonna wear and
you know you're entering that culture
and so you know I had a beautiful wrap
and so mayor you wore it like you know
you're honoring a word almost like
there's a burka and you board one of my
skirts and I had so much fun dressing
you up and I thought you look so
stunning and so beautiful do you
remember that moment I do I sent the
picture to my mom she said you look like
a nun
not what we're going for but but the
point is your sincerity in that you know
I mean we just want to support you and
then you said no you got to do what's
right in this situation I was like okay
um but you find the way but I I really
appreciate you making that honoring I
think loving yourself is as simply as
doing those little things that you would
do for someone you love they're kind
things they're gentle things they're
conscious things there's like creating
room for them or like me not wanting you
have to go through that so all right
I'll cancel the meeting you know it
doesn't matter who it is but but then
it's you at the same time saying no this
is what's best and both of us operating
from a frame of not what we're not
trying to get what we want we're trying
to serve the other yes that's what love
is that's what you do with your child
that's what you do with your dearest
friends and that's what you would
hopefully do with your intimate so what
gets in the way of that is not that you
don't just love yourself because quite
frankly you know I would say for a good
portion of my life I wouldn't say I
didn't love myself but it certainly
didn't flow at the level it does for you
you've been a role model for me on that
now it's different today you know at
about to be 63 years old
um I've you know I've hit a sweet spot
at some point but the reason I'm
bringing this up is if you're hard on
yourself being hard to yourself
separates you from Love And so I've had
to learn I used to beat myself up I
hadn't done enough created enough for
you for the family for anybody for
anything and what I've learned the last
few years and when I beat myself up it
separates me it makes I'm not present
for you I'm not present for the family I
wouldn't so I really don't do it anymore
but it was a lifelong habit but I but I
also want people to know that if it's
hard for you to quote love yourself you
can be kind to yourself yes you can do
some simple things for yourself you do
for others and if your wiring is I gotta
do something of value then do something
of value I want people to know it can be
more than you can imagine but you have
to not just love yourself you have to
get outside of yourself yeah you got to
find something to serve you care about
more than yourself that's when your
fears and your angers and your
frustrations disappear is when you're
serving and when as long as we're in our
own self it's just the nature of the
mind is to dissect break things down
find out what's not right what's not
what's not good enough so you can leave
that by service and you can also still
be service of yourself and then the
other thing I just want to mention is
what kills love more than anything else
or at least you know intimacy for sure
is the law familiarity it's the law
familiarity says that if you're around
anything enough
you tended to just take it a little bit
for granted you know somebody gets a
brand new car and they're a young kid or
you're a young professional and that car
represented some hard work you did
forever had some image for you or some
identity for you bless you honey and and
then you get in the car and it's amazing
and then one day there's a scratch and
you're like oh my God I can't believe
somebody scratched my car and then you
know next day scratch and after about
six weeks you got four or five scratches
it's a car you know but unfortunately
that's what people treat their
relationship they get used to it the
things in the beginning you would you
know you would never say to your partner
you wouldn't say to a stranger you say
to your partner because it's safe and
it's not it's not kind so I think we all
have to constantly you you and I do this
all three of us do this we know that our
love is a is a accumulation of our
communication and we talk about how much
we love each other time I say how do I
get so lucky to get you how do I get so
lucky to have this extraordinary family
have we get lucky to have our daughter
it's those conversations that are
sincere that are ongoing with yourself
as well as your partner or with your
friends that make it happen but you
gotta the law familiarity is natural
unfortunately so is gravity but if you
let gravity you'll be on the ground you
have to push against it and I think what
a lot of couples and a lot of friends
even need to do is reawaken the newness
in their relationship and that's just by
getting curious again and again by being
less judgmental I always say to people
you know people say how do you have this
ability to influence people or parents
will come to me sometimes say say this
to my kid and well why don't you want me
to say that and you're not going to say
it well because they'll listen to you
but it's not that it's it's that I I I
don't judge anybody I know we're all
here at Earth school I know we're all
figuring it out I know people make giant
mistakes I know most people have done or
said something at some point they wish
they never have and our culture is
totally unforgiving of that now but
reality is that's humans and so you
can't really in my you're not going to
consistently influence somebody for a
greater good while you're judging them
but if you're loving them and they can
feel that that can get through almost
any barrier and that's how we've been on
the suicide interventions the people so
stuck that you know there's no way
you're going to get through them but we
get through to them and I get through
them as well by truly loving them and if
you do that not once not conveniently
not as a technique if you do that enough
you can get through to anybody there is
no Force grader on Earth and there's no
more attracting Force to your life all
the beautiful people in our life honey
that we consider chosen family are
attracted because we love them
unconditionally and they love us
unconditionally and it's like it's a
virtuous cycle that everyone deserves to
have but it requires you getting out of
the conditioning of trying to protect
yourself and it requires to be
vulnerable it requires you to give up
the negativity that you have just
because you're afraid of being
disappointed yes and the jadedness as
long as you keep that jadedness it might
look cool or act cool but it's going to
leave you empty and as you're speaking
tone just thinking as well the Curiosity
to you know who is this beautiful
universe going to bring into my life
today because you really never know I
mean I I just wanted to share as well a
gesture of
such love such kindness such creativity
that blew me away tone that I never
considered or thought of when Mary was
carrying our daughter and she was
pregnant
um maybe you were about seven or eight
months I think and you came to me and
you were like you know what like this
woman our daughter wouldn't be here if
it wasn't for you Mary and I really
think we should see if we could uh
legally apply for adoption so that you
could be an adoptive parent
and I remember going to bed that night
and thinking like that wouldn't have
even occurred to me and I thought it was
so gracious I thought it was so creative
I thought it was so kind I thought it
was so considerate uh you walked in your
shoes and and I'm only sharing this
story right now because you know love
can look so different and so much more
beautiful than The Narrative of the
expectation of the story that we might
have of something that we want to get
and then here life blesses us with this
unexpected
unbelievably like just beautiful gift
that uh I'll speak for myself you bless
my life with to be a mom
and uh you know the I don't know what
the word is but the magnanimous I don't
know if that's the word but
that magnanimous gesture tone of you
walking in Mary's shoes at that time and
seeing that you know you were only
birthing our daughter you were birthing
being a mother you know that was
birthing as you you could see it it was
so gorgeous to watch you at that stage
and to watch you know all these
different pieces and parts of yourself
you know life is always reconfiguring
within us and every experience you know
I really believe is calling us to be
more of our true nature or recognizing
our whole self and I watched pregnancy
is that for you but I wouldn't have
thought of that I I think you're selling
you're so sure it didn't occur to me but
I wouldn't I wouldn't have brought it to
you if it wasn't your nature already I
just I knew that I wanted to make sure
everything happened to us that Mary knew
since she'd brought this child on that
she's mom too and then I thought about
you know and I wanted to feel like oh I
I've worked now what happens this family
separates and now I have no play in this
child's life that she gave us the gift
of sharing together but I couldn't have
done that if you didn't have the soul
that you have that made me know that
you're you and I may do the same stuff
that you'd step in people's shoes all
the time and by doing that but but my
favorite part of that old experience
besides you Mary knowing for sure that
you have unconditional love and that
she's your baby as well was when we went
to the judge because this was kind of a
breakthrough in Florida and said we want
to apply for you know the third parents
of the three of us together and the
judge you normally do you have Married
Too Much
Mary was very stressed that day
if she says no we're gonna get this
through but they made it clear they
don't say during the session today they
tell you a couple weeks later they're
not going to give you an answer today
but why don't you share it I think
that's a great idea
right now just behaving
hi sweetheart hi baby
sorry well no
um it's perfect right on time out there
so we had you know we went through the
legal paperwork and things for the
application process and this was all
during covet so they when we got a court
date they said it was going to be
through zoom and
um I came to the psych evaluation all of
us and I was worried my wife was going
to pass or not with the weirdness going
on you were too married Tony we're
preparing
me
that's weird
and so we had this Zoom with the judge
and we're all you know lined up like
little ducklings on the couch holding
her best foot forward and we've got our
baby on our lap and we're zooming with
the judge
and we're practicing you know okay we
say your honor and this is what we're
applying for
and someone who would set up our Zoom
you know how the little name is on the
bottom of of your screen and someone had
set it up that said Robin's family Zoom
so it was the three of us and baby
and I remember the judge almost within
the first 60 seconds of her coming on
she said she stared at us there was a
moment where she looked up and stared us
and we're all there on the couch and
we're feeling pretty full of emotion and
this is a key moment
what'd you say well she said that I'm
looking at this family right now and I
can see that you guys are a family and
so before we even had she even pressed
us on the questions that our lawyer told
us she'll ask you this she'll ask you
that she could ask you anything and I'm
Sweating Bullets like what is she gonna
ask us and she felt it she felt the love
I guess that's probably the point you
could feel the love the the family was
exuding that love it wasn't about some
right or wrong answer that we could give
at that point yeah the energy of what
she saw in front of her she said I I
feel a level of Love here that I rarely
see in my life and she said so I just
want you to know well we can discuss all
the details uh but we're not going to
wait I'm going to tell you right now you
guys are clearly a family all we're
doing is making it official for you
right now it was quite a celebratory day
but it's again it's the experience of
love that's unmistakable when it's
authentic and real
and what Sage said tone is like your
creativity and caring my favorite riffs
that you ever have when you're you know
when you're teaching is those wands I'm
like it's not about money it's not about
it's creativity and caring yeah your
ability to give and your you know
contributions and your love it's all
comes back to creativity and caring and
I don't know that for me has been the
lesson of everything you've ever taught
me that it's like even in all different
kinds of love so even like when I'm
writing a little note to my mom it's
like how can I be more creative with
this and how can I really get through so
it's not just you know you're if you
like if you're unmarried like me or if
it's not about that kind of love any now
any dealing I have if I'm writing to a
brother or sister an old friend it's
like I'm always saying to myself like
creativity and caring how can they feel
my love through it's the essence of what
you teach everywhere like get creative
get resourceful walk in their shoes meet
them where they are what would light
them up when people think of Lifestyle
they think of things when lifestyle is
all relationships yes but as you said
it's not like oh you have the money to
do something it's not that it's thinking
about how do we do it in a way that
produces surprise or awe or feeling
overwhelmed overwhelmingly appreciated
or enjoyed or it's like I live to create
those moments for our clients for our
friends for our chosen family you know
for each other and nothing gives you
more joy I mean in life what gives what
gives us the lasting Joy not the
temporary energy of excitement it's
almost always something that where you
grew where inside you you face something
difficult you grew and then because you
grew there's an Insight there's a
feeling there's emotion there's a
greater strength there's a greater
capacity to care and now you're able to
share something like whenever we have
something beautiful happens in our life
what's the first thing you want to do
share with somebody you love because it
magnifies it that's what relationship is
it's the magnifier of human notion so if
you're both really messed up in a really
terrible place you'll magnify the
negative but if you're coming from just
a warm loving kind as simple as those
words are a place it opens the door for
a deeper level of love for anyone it
does and I love Tony that you just said
about growth as well because if I think
of this constellation and every day as a
parent and as I observe uh you know both
of you parents as I observe you
mothering as I observe you fathering as
I observe this little lady in our life
and sometimes I'll watch you and I think
like gosh I would never do that as a mom
and you know when we are dropping and we
I willing to get out of our human self
when we drop our judgments and we just
observe this beautiful love in life that
you know we are blessed with here now
wherever you are listening to this you
know it's just it's it's a miracle and
it's a gift to share it with you too
right now but I do just want to say that
I feel like I'm a better human being
because and I've been stretched that
whole process is certainly as much as
it's been a blessing there's been
moments where it's been a stretch all
the different pieces of you caring uh
you know our daughter and uh then you
know mind coming through well she bond
to me will she want to go to me you'll
be breastfeeding like all these human
even if you you know love is so blessed
and life is so abundant we all have
those thoughts to transcend because they
are just a thought when I believe them I
really suffered you know I doubted
myself for all the feelings of not
enough so you say beating yourself up
that can be part of this Human
Experience and I think a gift of love is
taking responsibility for our in inner
stuff our inner Discord and Rising above
that noise so that we can notice and
recognize something different and I'm
amazed and humbled every day at just the
beautiful ordinary simple moments and uh
and people are always surprised when
they come to see us anything else to
expect us to be like okay Partiers I
don't know what they expect but we're
home buddies because of the littlest
things in life that we appreciate we'd
certainly have the privilege of playing
on a global scale and interacting with
extraordinary human beings of every type
you could imagine but it's those small
intimate moments that make life blasting
and every study on happiness and people
everybody wants to be happy right or
it's some version of that they want a
life that's meaningful all of those show
that the number one factor above all
else is the quality of relationships the
quality of relationships the quality of
your life but in order to have that I
think we've got to certainly be kinder
to ourselves and and you've got to you
want to be the kind of person that you
would love like I work hard to be the
person I I I I I have a hard time dang
it you have no difficulty because I love
myself but I appreciate this man I've
become with God's guidance and my focus
and effort and a lot of Grace but it's
um I can look at my life and I can be
proud of who I am as a human no matter
what anybody else knows I know inside
the journey that I've gone on the people
I've gotten to serve the conversations
I've had the the experiences of
transformation Within Myself and within
my businesses and with my friends and
family and strangers and so the
accumulation of all that also for those
who think are difficult to yourself I
know some of it may come with
accumulation of years too I don't know
it's not a guarantee accumulation yours
doesn't guarantee happiness but I think
there's a place for those of us who've
been wired for contribution and wired
for achievement where there's a point
where you finally have to plant flag and
say okay we've won this thing but I
think the real I I want to leave you
guys here before I turn it over to you
with just thinking about holding
yourself to a standard I think the
quality the best relationship is
somebody that you want to be more for
than you even for yourself I think I
don't think that's a bad thing I think
one of the beautiful things about human
beings is that we'll do more for others
we care about than we will for ourselves
I think that's that's the humanity in
humans you know that's the beauty and
the best part of us and so you got to be
worthy of that and one way to do that is
kind of set a standard for yourself it's
like it's like in Life or in business
what measured what you know what you
don't measure doesn't get better right
if you're going to make a business
happen there's no management if there's
no measurement so one thing that I
measure is I ask myself consciously over
the years and now it's pretty much
automatic for me but what level love is
this
and so I look at love as like four
dimensions I look at as the First
Dimension is like baby love and when I
say that I don't mean the love that you
have for your baby I mean a person whose
standards are the baby because the
babies if I said are babies loving we
all go yes and especially with our
daughter we feel that completely no
question about it you're right over
there peering through the glass right
now I'm being so good
um but it's the truth is they're only
loving and happy when they're getting
what they want
right that's because that's the stage of
development it's about me me me as it
should be at that stage of development
but some people are 50 and they're still
doing baby love and they're angry if
they don't get if you don't give me
everything I want those relationships if
they last they don't last very long and
they might last in years but they don't
last them love because nobody wants to
be in a place where you're always trying
to get something from me as I said
earlier you want a place to give the
second level of Love is he could say
Where am I playing right now my
relationship or my friendship or in my
business even with the people around me
am I demanding love or demanding
attention demanding everything that's
baby love then there's horse trading
every level two second dimension
two-dimensional love and that's where
okay I'm doing all this for you and but
even if I don't admit it to myself
there's conscious trading like I'm doing
this so that you'll learn something yeah
give me something and there's
unconscious horse trading that's the
person who gives gives gives until one
day they get so mad because someone has
been giving back so they've always been
horse trading and horse trading is not
love yes it's a transaction as I said
earlier and a transaction might be fine
but even in business transactions don't
create raving fans and I've been both of
those by the way I was going to say I've
been sure a horse trader I've been uh uh
you know selfish we've all been all
perspectives as you're listening to this
and thinking oh my gosh I've been really
stuck in that we've all been stuck there
at times that's the gift you know as
we're we're evolving that's right but if
you can be aware of it you can get stuff
out of it awareness by itself can start
to break the pattern so I'm bringing it
forward to you and then there's the
third dimension of Love
three-dimensional love which is truly
unconditional love which is you love
because it's who you are you love you
know the biggest mistake you see in
relationships is some people think
they're going to punish their partner
because if they compliment too much or
they're too nice to them they won't have
control over them I mean again control
and love don't go together
um but when you're just when you
withhold love the person you always
heard is yourself so very often you said
earlier about you know expressing love
you might express love to this person I
never give it back to you but it comes
back all around you in the other places
because it becomes who you are and other
people whose hearts are open are
beginning to open will respond to you
and then the fourth level of Love is
loving someone even is hurting you now
that doesn't mean you stay in a
relationship like that with someone
who's hurting you but it means that you
don't let them harm you don't stay in
the environment but you don't hate them
you know you know we you you know we
know the Dalai Lama quite well and it's
been some wonderful time with him and
he's what such a beautiful soul with his
humor and his laughter and his kindness
but I mean imagine someone taking your
heritage taking your country and also
you know trying to kill you and he still
prays for the soldiers not like oh I'm
so much better than they are like he
does he does he wants to be free of
guilt no guilt he wants them to have joy
in their hearts
um Mother Teresa certainly did that
Nelson Mandela one of the greatest human
beings I've ever had the privilege of
meeting to be able to take the people
that imprison him for a quarter of a
century and try to enter their world
into their shoes and what are they
thinking what they're feeling um we can
we have a chance to touch people I just
got back from my aunt's funeral and I'm
I just I I every person that got up to
speak I was just I was so struck by what
we all know but we forget it's like the
littlest things we do touch other people
the littlest kindness the littlest
caring the little bit of laughter the
little bit of focus and attention and I
just think in this month of Valentine's
maybe expand Beyond Valentine's and say
Where am I playing in my relationships
level one two three or four not beat
yourself up but if it's one or two it's
time to step up and that takes a little
courage it takes a little vulnerability
it takes some Faith but you can we don't
we're not all Mother Teresa we're not
all Nelson Mandela but we all have the
capacity
and and we're not all do it all the time
but the more you go to places like that
the easier it is just to be
unconditional and you're loving and like
I said before I don't know of a stronger
force on Earth to attract people to you
in life in family and business than to
feel that there is a sincere
pudding of them first you know in the
financial world you know the the concept
of you know being in a position where
you're a fiduciary big F word and what
it really means is you put the needs of
that person ahead of your own and the
law requires somebody's fiduciary to
actually do that well what if your law
of life was to be a fiduciary for the
people around you to be the person that
looks out for their best interests first
and you don't have to worry about your
own because if you really do do that
your life is so so much love and so much
friendship and from that so much
opportunity and so much meaning that
that whatever was your biggest goal of
your life before will look like a
cartoon compared to the quality of life
you'll create so I encourage people to
measure not measure with harshness but
just practicality and say how am I
playing right now and if I'm not there
and by the way it can change moment to
moment and and I've done one and I've
been two as well but I pride myself in
keeping the three and four as much as
possible the more you do it the more it
becomes your identity the more it comes
your identity the more it just happens
naturally it's not hard it's some new
habits habits of kindness habits of
warmth habits of putting yourself in the
other person's shoes and habits of
honoring yourself as well in the process
the combination of that can be a
revolution in somebody's life in my
experience thank you honey I couldn't
help but when you were talking about
level four that you know for those of
you who may be transitioning in a
relationship because I think that's a
great opportunity to practice this a lot
of times we think that you know during a
divorce or separation that it's like you
know oh there's no love there or it's a
Loveless marriage and yet maybe it's an
opportunity in those moments for more
love not less to lean into it and even
if you decide and gosh you know what I I
choose not to spend the rest of my life
with this individual it's true for me
and for us to you know go a different
way
finding those threads of Common Ground
looking for ways to be kind you'd shared
a big part of your life it doesn't have
to be so painful it doesn't have to be
so clunky we really can do it
consciously and kindly and if you didn't
and if you haven't 20 years later we
have the opportunity you need to tidy it
up yeah for sure and uh that's the gift
of Grace that's the gift of compassion
that's the gift of mercy and that's the
gift of this Human Experience is that
we've all been blind we've all been
unconscious and so you know and we all
have an opportunity to realign and to
tune and to offer what's more sincere
here now I couldn't agree more I love
you too human beings
I'm going to turn you back over to this
family of mine that I love so much and
that you have just their perspective
um and um I know that most of you if
you're listening to this right now are
still listening and haven't turned us
off and go oh this is a bunch of BS
syrupy stuff then some part of your soul
knows it to be true so don't have to
make it a big deal it's those little
steps that start to link together into
new habits and then that shapes it
brings you back to your true character I
think the character we all have before
we get by fear and pain and loss and
disappointment and all the things that
are just a part of the natural
experience and I'd just say also it's
like what is love the biggest way to
have more love is to focus on what you
appreciate and give up your expectations
I always say you know
the fastest way to change your life is
trade your expectations you know for
your appreciation and there's always
some appreciation when you do that your
whole world changes and that's I really
the theme I think of what we're talking
about here it is I'll I also want to
maybe just acknowledge you and thank you
and thank you for those that are tuning
in and listening for sharing the Tony
Robbins podcast it extends to this
family and this wouldn't be happening
Mary it was your vision you uh you know
you've created it you've you know it's
been your inspiration and and you just
keep bringing these beautiful uh Notions
and and topics of conversation and I
just want to say thank you because your
whole passion was the world deserves to
know different faces of love and I can't
thank you enough for uh you know having
the vision of this and the inspiration
of this and you've worked so hard on
this whole project and tone thank you
for sharing the Tony Robbins podcast and
for those of you too love you dearly
maybe I got a front row seat to this
love and it's too beautiful to not share
it not put it out there although it's
because of you that it is and for those
of you who tune in thank you for being
so cool and awesome and willing to share
uh you know just in a in and have this
family be expanded and have our share
our inner world with you so thank you
for your love of offering your heart and
spending the time with us today okay
guys I've gotta go to my scheduled
meetings that are mine but I'm so
grateful you invited me for taking this
and I'm gonna turn you on our family and
our extended audience out listening in
to this two beautiful soul set here that
I love so so much they're gonna take
over from here thank you guys thank you
tone you're always welcome here at the
Tony Robbins podcast
share
[Music]
uh Mary I love that this topic has come
up for us and and that we decided to
have a conversation
um you know with Valentine's Day and the
focus on romantic love which is an
aspect of love but as we all know it is
certainly is uh much more Broad and
um
beautiful
then that love alone uh you know I think
sometimes in society or in life we have
the perception that
love is coming from outside of ourselves
and uh and with that innocently we as
humans Place demands or expectations
because it's something that we want to
get I want love I want you to love me I
want to find the love of my life I want
a mate I I I want I want and that
perception or filter or lens of Love is
deducting because it's something that
number one we don't have control of from
the love of the outside but truthfully
the love that we experience from my own
experience is the love that we are
uh and
um I think that's the most beautiful
awareness or reality is recognizing that
our nature is love
you that reminds me of how at um
some seminars or relationship seminar a
date with Destiny seminar oftentimes
Tony you guys have an exercise where
you'll ask the audience to make a list
yes and say write down all the things
think of your ideal relationship think
of your ideal partner make a list of
everything you'd like them to be what do
they look like what do they act like
what's their sense of humor like what
everything what's their favorite book
and people come up with these long lists
and then Tony will say okay now make a
list of the love that you would have to
be to attract that person that you just
yes described and we often have a little
laugh because people's lists of how they
would have to be as love is often a lot
shorter than the list of that the other
would have to give so in in you know uh
media social media or the lens of the
world love the word itself has been so
distorted you know the word itself has
been so deluded or deducted and that a
lot of people innocently don't even
believe in the reality that they are
love or that love is possible
you know love is gosh what's that prayer
love is gentle and kind uh those two
attributes are so missed you know love
is gentle it is kind it's it's inclusive
it's accepting there's an allowance you
know gosh having you know our our
daughter and having a little one at this
stage and you know gosh she's just 20
months and it's so remarkable to me that
whether you you know she pees on you
throws up on you or every other bodily
function that transpires
um you know there's just this
this enjoyment this appreciation this uh
Adoration of the experience of the
Innocence and the Purity and I think
through the filter maybe through the you
know I don't know these movies or these
ideal you know or or different cartoons
that portray this you know maybe
princess and prince and you know this
individual is going to come and you know
save you uh there's a Miss of the
beautiful awesome reality of how we are
created and when we connect to that when
we tune into that when we tap into that
reality
um it's so beautiful because then we
just get to extend that we get to share
that
um rather than unconditionally rather
than expect that and for those of you
who are listening
maybe you think like that's not true
that's not my experience just look to
where
just find that truth if you can maybe it
isn't with your partner but maybe it's
with a really dear friend that it's like
I freaking love this person there's
nothing that they could do you know it's
just that unconditional love and
acceptance maybe it's with your child
maybe it's with your grandmother or your
pet your dog I know that sounds crazy
but I have felt that way and you have
made me feel that way before
and I don't I don't know that this is
too much of a stretch but just to give
you an example
um a long time ago almost about 10 years
ago I don't know what story this is
going to be so that's well I mean we're
different people
um as as anyone listening is you're a
different person now than you were 10
years ago or I mean I'm foreshadowing to
try to have some caveats about the story
I'm going to tell but
I had not gotten sober yet I was still
drinking Tony I had met you guys I was
working we were working on Tony's book
money Master the game so I'm working
hard etc etc and was here on business
for long days and nights and sometimes
weeks staying at the hotel
and as I mentioned I was still drinking
at this time
sometimes more heavily than than I would
have liked to admit and I was walking
down the hotel hallway I'll never I've
never told this story I don't think to
anyone I was walking down the hallway
and kind of like you know like a pinball
from door to door
on uncertain unsure footing
and not one of my best moments it's hard
for me even to
to picture the girl that was walking
down that hallway fumbling with her
hotel Key trying to find the right hotel
room and I looked down the hallway and
you were standing there and I had a
moment of like I was mortified I was
shocked I was embarrassed I was
humiliated and I wanted to hide there's
nowhere to hide in a hotel hallway right
and like if I could have thrown a black
hole on the ground and dove in it I
would have and I'm just like
I mean had this flood of emotion of like
there goes everything There Goes My Life
there goes my job there's no way I'm not
gonna get fired I can't even stand up
straight and you came over and you were
just like hey mayor hey man you didn't
know and I was like I mean honestly
probably what was I afraid of I was
probably afraid that I was going to lose
your love because you and I were very
good friends even at that point yes
it makes me emotional think about
because I was just like I was terrified
and ashamed and just thinking
she's never everything that I've ever
known with her is gone and you were just
like looks like you need some help
getting me into my room yes I remember
that remember this I do remember that
story and I love that that's what uh was
uh stirred out through this conversation
uh I remember when you left you didn't
feel yourself and uh definitely
continued to linger in my being and I
felt uneasy and uh by the way you know
uh innocently we as human beings you
know we feel these instincts and I think
it's so beautiful when we tune in and
and you know act and that was one of
those moments and I remember walking
down the hallway and seeing you and
I just had I had love and compassion for
you I was like oh my gosh I got to get
you in that room I gotta get that kid
and help you open that door
and uh you know love is birthed through
many moments of that where
um you know when you love it's it's it
wasn't about what I thought you should
be doing or shouldn't be doing I
couldn't care less you know I I cared
about you and and I wanted you supported
and uh to know that hey I was there
um and you know uh I'm just so surprised
that you're sharing this conversation or
this story well maybe I think at the
right place I think it's actually really
beautiful I think it's really beautiful
because it's a reminder that love sees
through a lens there is you know love
doesn't judge you know love accepts it
allows it understands it connects
um yes we're speaking of Corinthians
don't quote me on that but I think
that's the prayer that you were
mentioning I think the love is pain
patient love is kind yes
I I expect it to be met with disgust and
judgment and you just it wasn't like you
weren't laughing it was just it felt
nothing but compassion and like and that
that moment of Love is what made me be
like I got something's got to change
well that's beautiful how many years
they've been sober maybe I am going on
seven years that's incredible that's
awesome I haven't had a drink in seven
years I can't believe it and it's
probably worth mentioning in the love
podcast if alcohol is something that you
don't have a healthy relationship with
um I would not have been able to admit
this I would have been like it's it is
not unhealthy in fact it is the
lubricant that I need for my emotions to
go into that direction of of I mean love
is probably the wrong wrong word there
that's not love but for relationships or
life for life I wouldn't have thought I
would be able to function without it and
this is not an advertisement to do that
I'm just saying if you hear this in any
part of you goes ah man my relationship
I would have a lot less problems if I
wasn't if I didn't have maybe some
problems myself with alcohol or whatever
whatever your thing is everybody's got
something probably and when you find
someone that will love you through that
and you want to be better for
that's a powerful thing and it's also an
example of it doesn't have to be your
you know this isn't some romantic story
this is this person loved me enough
to make me say I don't ever want to be
that because I was judging myself as
disgraceful and and if that was my
impression of myself in that moment
I don't want to be that for you and you
made me see that I don't want to be that
for me and love does that well I think
that's you just stumbled upon something
that a lot of times culturally or or in
this world that we can miss because love
really does start with ourselves and uh
I simply reflected who you are mayor in
that moment or maybe possibly reminded
you who you are
um and I think we're all doing that or
we all have the opportunity to do that
for each other
and that's the gift of that's where we
meet in this Human Experience and by the
way if it isn't alcohol we all numb
ourselves or can distract ourselves or
um you know there's many different ways
to do such things and if it is an
alcohol it might be food or if it isn't
food it might be this you know we can
all walk down that path and
um and then there's another way which is
actually leaning into it and stepping
through it and understanding what's
coming up
um you know I was thinking about this
conversation and uh thinking about like
where does unconditional love fit in
this society and I think it you know for
myself anyway anyways or from my own
experience more accurately
it's the understanding that we are all
in this thing together you know we all
have this internal experience of mind
that uh you know there's those two
voices with inside of ourselves it's
like the one that is a greater Trooper a
broader truth or that truth for
ourselves uh and there's one that's kind
of the naysayer that's you can't do this
or this that or the other like you said
you know shameful or disgust that wasn't
even my reference point
um but I think that's so remarkable that
we all have that flight we all walk that
path no matter where we come from what
religion what race what education and I
think that that juncture that Oneness
that we are all in this Human Experience
I mean gosh you know you look at people
from
a Prince Harry from you know our beloved
twitch that you know just uh you know
took his life most recently and it's
like oh my gosh you know you wouldn't
think of maybe somebody in a position of
that nature or a certain level of fame
or that one might perceive that oh my
gosh they have everything uh but you
know we are still having to navigate
that inner world of mind and the doubts
and the fears and and so forth and
hopefully question and inquire and
transcend those pieces I think that's
the opportunity for us all and I think
that you know recognizing that you know
the same force that beats my heart beats
your heart beats Ethan's heart beats all
of our hearts everybody that's listening
that is where we meet I think that's
gorgeous Sage oftentimes ends I tease
you because like you'll end many
sentences with that's where we all meet
and which I take to mean like that is
the collective that psychologists talk
about that's the collective Human
Experience and so tone teaches that we
all have many fears fear of rejection
fear of failure fear of too much success
but the primary fear that we all meet in
is this fear of we're not enough not
enoughness insufficiency we're not
enough and so we won't be loved
and which is just a thought by the way
it's just I'm not a not I'm not enough
is simply just a thought if we believe
it we really suffer but it's just to for
those of you who are listening we all
have that thought and if we believe it
we really go down a rabbit hole and the
gift of this Human Experience is the
capacity to be able to question its
right I mean to interrupt you I just
that's exactly it so I think you're
saying it's just a thought so for any of
us who feel at times in moments it can
feel debilitating and of course people
take their life for people who talk
about what struggles with mental illness
or just I mean without even putting
labels on it just feeling like I can't
do this anymore it's usually like a
feeling of like
I I don't I don't know what to do I
don't know which way to go any way I go
I'm not going to be enough I'm not going
to find an answer
and feeling that sense of overwhelm like
you just you don't have what it takes to
do it whatever it is and you're saying
hey
when all that pressure feels like it's
like physically on you it is just a
thought that you're believing well it is
if we believe that thought you know that
and that narrative becomes a part of our
internal uh tapestry that's a really
painful reality and I've been there
there's been so many circumstances that
have come up in my own life that
um
I would love for you to talk a little
bit about like your own life give us
give us a little touch for a second on
like you and Tony have been together
forever we see these images 22 guys
you're such a beautiful couple
it's not to say that tone and I haven't
been to Heaven and Hell and Hell again
in Heaven Again internally you know
individually and collectively
um there's been times I don't know you
you know the beginning of a relationship
of any relationship especially I can't
see a new relationship that's not
accurate in an in more of an intimate
relationship of a dynamic there's we
have more Impressions or conditioning
around an expectation of who they're
supposed to be and that's brutal that's
painful you know I remember
in in the in the early days of you know
I want you to be present for me I want
you to understand me I want you to like
all these that's ridiculous so
ridiculous yeah and and and then when
that person doesn't match that of your
you know crazy expectation of that and
then we go into our inside of ourselves
and we suffer and it disconnect and then
we're not loving
ourselves never mind them that gets
weird and it gets clunky and so I feel
like the first I don't know how long um
you know you spend the first probably
decade getting over yourself
you know getting over yourself and
understanding yourself and
um so that you know you you pretty much
I feel like we're Tony and I are at this
stage we're left with love and gratitude
like we are left with love and gratitude
I love that man and whatever makes them
happy whatever that looks like
um I want that for him you know and he
wants that for me and I think that's
what I'd want for our daughter I want
her happiness I have love and gratitude
for the experience but I have no
expectation of that she needs to be
something other than what she is and
that's Freedom you know that's Freedom
it's our demands it's like I love you if
I love you when you do this I love you
when you marry me you know I want this
once again it's this these weird strange
demands that we place on this
notion of love and yet that's not love
it destroys love
it it it it yeah it's controlling it it
what's that word like
um yeah constricts or strangles love uh
not love uh our experience of it because
when we have those expectations we shut
off our own you know love is a currency
it's a it's a resonance and uh you can
feel it you can walk into the room and
feel that experience it's an invisible
force you can't see it you can't hold on
to it you can't control it uh but it's a
happening it's a beautiful happening and
um and it extends you know every just
today you know this beautiful man in
this room here hi Ethan
who's uh filming this you know I walked
in and just saw his face and it's like
wow it's so beautiful to be with you I
have a love for him who he is and I
think that's where life really gets
beautiful to when you recognize you know
whatever you want to call it if you're
not a believer in God if you are it's
like we're all children of God God if
you're not it's like the same force that
breathes my breath breathes yours
breathes yours and that's so that
there's this interconnectedness of the
of this Oneness and all of a sudden this
equality or I don't know the equality is
the right word but this uh meeting point
this juncture that what that I was
created you were created you were
created and I'm going through this Human
Experience you're going through this
Human Experience we all experience you
know life and like death and you know
all this this Human Experience or not
enoughness and it's like what
so such sweet compassion and and
appreciation for us everyone I mean how
could you not and I think when you have
that lens whether them oh they're this
they're this political party they're
this religion they're this whatever race
or this that it's like okay that is a
description that is an identity that
might be a facet but that's not who you
are that's not who I am we are so much
more beautiful and complex and and and
and and and
um
intricate I don't know that that's even
the word I know our friend Mickey singer
talks about open and close can you maybe
speak to that a little bit well uh you
know you can feel intrinsically inside
yourself when you're open and connected
and feeling that
um there's a spaciousness inside you uh
there's a willingness there's a
receptivity there's an aliveness to life
to
um and you know closing is uh you know
feels very different it feels tight it
feels constricted it feels can feel
fearful because you're believing your
thoughts you know
um it's humbling and we all experience I
experience that that dance I know what
it feels like to feel that heavy density
of feeling like oh and feeling fear or
that tightness or constriction and what
it feels like on the other side of that
you know even if you're just like yep
nope uh the people that you really love
that shortness is a is a closing is a
constriction of it is is constriction of
the the faucet we modulate our love if
they do this oh we give them this
response if they do that oh they get
this response that's closing that's
opening and closing that's what we mean
I think when we talk about that and
tuning when I learned that and then
tuning into that feeling
it's it's a great little yardstick well
I think that's one of the gifts of this
Human Experience is that or the I don't
know if it's a gift well I think it is a
gift um is that we are all responsible
for our life and as well that inner
tapestry or that inner Discord or Inner
Harmony you know and so uh you know if
you're feeling that uh resistance or if
you're feeling that tightness or that
constriction Less Pleasant you know
um it's a gift of inquiry or even
identifying chewing in what am I even
believing in order to be experiencing
this because it's a belief or it's a
story it's a narrative and it's usually
happening this way something from
yesterday if you think of like if all of
your life was completely erased up till
this very moment
then all we are would be experiencing is
this moment the sensations inside of
ourselves what we see what we feel what
we perceive and think about it like if
you just literally walked into this
planet it's like what the Eternal
Sunshine of the Spotless Mind this
beautiful reality yes this beautiful
moment
this exact moment all you have to do is
close your eyes to tap into it you know
what my heart's beating I woke up this
morning sometimes I'll wake up and I'll
see my feet on the ground and I'm like
oh hello like I don't know like I have
this body this thing that carries me
around it blows my mind and that when I
think of that miracle I fall in love I'm
like wow I'm really grateful to be alive
today life can change in an instant but
as I was driving we were to talking last
night and he was driving down the street
the other day and this truck drove by in
this really big block of wood hit the
front of his vehicle and uh he was like
like it number one Beyond startling him
he thought like a bomb went off he
didn't know what happened but he was
like like life can change in an instant
you know in an instant uh we just never
know uh when our last breath will be and
I think it's beautiful to live it so
fully so utterly and leave nothing on
the table
um so that you know there's a fullness
to life I don't know I think it's a
beautiful experience to get into bed and
feel like whoa what a live today that's
love you know that's love it's true
absolutely you know and if you're in a
relationship if you're not if you have
children if you don't if you have
parents if you have friends like
whatever if you're straight if you're
gay if you're whatever whatever you
whatever's true for you however love
expresses or life expresses as you
um you know that's really what this is
all being or I'll be all about and uh
you know I wanted to say one more thing
about you know when you mention about
Tony and I and
like the acceptance I I think one of the
most gorgeous recognitions when you
realize that it's like I am you you are
me and so you know at the beginning stop
right there though explain that okay
well
the same I have judgments I have fears I
feel sadness you feel ex like so we have
that meeting point so it's like if I'm
like oh you know she's this or he's
doing that or she's so it's like well
you know find all the places that you
are too yeah okay can't you of course if
you've felt not enough you felt like I
can't do this if you felt like you know
I I just I I can't we've all been there
we've all been there and so how can I or
how you know you can because mine judges
but I think that's just the recognition
that it's like I don't know somewhere
along the line uh you know after all
these years you start to recognize like
gosh who am I to point the finger who am
I to point the finger because what
somebody's yelling or you know they're
speaking in a harsh Voice or they're
cursing or they're slamming the door or
they're this I've done that
I've done that all me too so who the
heck am I to if you were drinking me
showing up that day and you were
drinking well what have I done to numb
myself many things you know we all have
and I think that that's just that's the
beauty of the recognition that that's
where we all come together that's the
true Oneness that we are all you know
brothers and sisters on this path that
that doesn't feel true to you we are all
but we are no matter where we come from
we are all in this Human Experience it
looks different for you than it does for
me for those of you listening at home
you know like maybe you're driving maybe
you're walking on the beach maybe you
have this on your iPhone maybe you're
cooking something but we all do these
things this we're all experiencing life
and I think that that is extraordinary
and that gets missed because there's so
much
innocent Focus about our differences or
what separates us but I think there's
this beautiful magnificent Universe of
what unites us and I you know I mean we
didn't just like stumble into life it's
a miracle you know what I mean like what
the heck life is a miracle the fact that
we are alive is a miracle and so to
that's love in itself to love life that
doesn't mean that you love everything
that happens it doesn't mean that
everything that happens is Pleasant
doesn't mean that people aren't going to
die you're not going to experience loss
you're not going to experience pain but
the beauty of it the mess of it the pain
of it
it's
it's life
and because we're experiencing that
we're alive and I think that's
incredible
and the balm you often use the word balm
the bomb that love can be in this life
that does entail at times yeah loss and
grief and struggle
then to know someone's love
that's pretty miraculous too yeah I'm
grateful for that you know it's just so
beautiful how God places these
unexpected Gifts of you know a human
through a glance through a reaching out
through somebody holding your hand
holding the space for you in an
unexpected way a hello you know a smile
the warmth of that the currency the
Resonance of that and what that feels
like that's love it's it's it's the most
simple ordinary what one may even
perceive to be mundane and yet so
incredibly profound that's love
in all forms in all forms sometimes
unexpected yes that was I was going to
mention when I'm bringing up finding
love let's say through dating apps which
is such a common experience and I just
want to be so clear I have zero Judgment
of that I've used them myself
successfully and unsuccessfully even
though there's no such thing
and what I do
think we maybe should at least be aware
of is we had a friend over for dinner
the other day and he is a daddiest two
um two sons in their 20s and he was
telling us how he and his wife had sat
with their sons and their son's
girlfriends and they were talking about
the experience of dating apps and what
that's like and how
you know and I'm not putting this on
them because I absolutely know this is
exactly what I did like you set your
filters right so and as you think like
oh this there's plenty of fish out there
and then we narrow our filters to like
this height and this eye color and this
you know just like the most ridiculous
prerequisites for things and so then by
by the time it's all said and done you
are working with like a three percent
stripe of the potential population
you're wondering like where are they I
can't find them it's like no you've
eliminated them and so
what I kind of what not even what I've
taken away what life has actually shown
me in my experience is
be surprised by those that will love you
and by those that you will be called to
love and they might not
fit into your little filters yes
um but you know if you say that we're
all children of God and if you're a
Believer or not a Believer if you
believe that something at least created
all of us or all of this
then you're offering that to some kind
of a higher power so and I hope that you
know we can see that there's got to be
something greater than us and so that
that Force must be more creative than
anything we can imagine yes and so if
you're limiting to like they have to be
this tall and you know they have to
speak three languages and they have to
be great at this and it's like we're
dumbing it down and like what about the
creative tone teach us about the the
most important things the ultimate
success formula is you have to stay
flexible and you have to be resourceful
and you got to get creative and these
are the things just like in anything
else that will make you quote unquote
successful I think when we're talking
about love even is like get creative
don't don't just work with this one
little like this is this is all I want
and this is all that will work for me
it's like where's the fun in that be
surprised let it you know get messy like
you said it's true and and a lot of
times those qualities they're about
action right you know it's not
necessarily even about love and love
looks different I mean you look at this
unique constellation of this family and
for those of you who didn't possibly
tune into our Mother's Day podcast Mary
uh carried our daughter she was the
surrogate and uh ended up being an
adoptive parent of our daughter and that
came through love you know that came
through this unexpected constellation of
these human Souls that were brought
together and brought this you know
beautiful being into existence and the
unexpectedness is this chosen family and
there's a sharing and it magnifies love
it makes life more beautiful in that
sharing and it's unexpected I never
imagined it uh you know it's it's
gorgeous and beautiful and of course has
its challenges as well but no different
than any human life would have its
challenges you know yes
love but it's it's so I couldn't have
created that I couldn't have wrote this
script you know through but it came out
of a painful circumstance it came out of
it was birthed out of you know not being
able to or miscarrying so many times and
and not being able to carry a child
myself and so this unexpectedness of
this you know this aggregate of of these
beautiful humans that came together
that humbles me and amazes me and I'm
not that intelligent or cool to think it
up and that would be missed on an app
not to say that you cannot fall in love
on an app I think they're you know
Wonderful because we can you know life
offers us love anywhere love defies the
odds or certainly this family has defied
the odds or the unexpectedness of how
this amazing constellation has come
together and I look at our daughter and
she has more love not less and
um because of it and you get to
experience what it's like to be a mother
to be a parent because of that really
courageous choice that you made to carry
her
I'm blessed with a gift to have a
daughter that I wouldn't have without
you know
um
you
without this amazing family and tone
being a father and this it's just it
blows me away and it humbles me every
day
um and I think you know
just talking to people and people in our
life I think you know a lot of times
parents are coming together or human
beings are coming together maybe you're
married before maybe you weren't maybe
you had children maybe you didn't maybe
want to have a child again whatever it
looks like or you know you're hanging
out with them and that's really cool and
that's enough it looks Life In Love
looks
so beautifully different and as diverse
as it possibly can as we are humans and
I think that's gorgeous
I do too and that doesn't mean I don't
wake up most mornings and think how did
I get here how did this happen
what did I always say God I do
that's your answer only every time and
it's true we told
um
do you guys have a friend who has a
mutual friend who is the Canadian
psychologist and author Jordan Peterson
so one day
they actually came over to the house and
Jordan and his wife and so you were I
remember this day
it was Tony and you and myself and baby
and you it was the first time we'd never
met we had no backstory on each other so
you were kind of introducing you and
kind of our our family to them and so
you kind of went through the whole thing
like you know Tony and I have been
married over 20 years and we have been
on the path to starting a family and
that hasn't been without its challenges
and
um you know so Mary actually carried our
child she's our surrogate but we all
live together now and we actually
legally pursued third parent adoption
and so this is the unique constellation
that we're living by and he I remember
him sitting there and just like taking
it all and by the way he's such a bright
mind and extremely Beyond it really
speaks with precision and his language
has such accuracy and I'm in my an
admirer of his work his biblical
lectures I think are some of the best
resources on the subject that exists
and he was you know taking this all we'd
like I'm going to say it again we had
just met and Sage gives him our kind of
family nutshell in in 30 seconds and uh
he was like that must require a lot of
negotiation and I'm not disagreeing with
him but I remember hearing him use that
word and I was like in my head I had
like kind of a head tilt like huh I
wonder what negotiation means to him I'm
sure he has a very precise
interpretation of that word
um and I got lost in my own like oh
negotiation interesting that that's what
that would mean to him okay and I'm just
like and before I could even think to
myself but that doesn't really resonate
with you and Tony and I in this
situation you looked at him extremely
respectfully I want to make that really
clear and just said no not when there's
love as a base not one there's virtue
not one you're all in servitude to each
other and I remember that moment and it
almost brings tears to my eyes because
your answer to nearly everything Sage
Robbins is love
like God love oh God it's one of the two
pretty much to everything and do you
remember that moment I remember that
moment I think I shared that I said it
was my experience or our experience that
it was the currency of love that there
really wasn't a negotiation
um you know I wanted you support it you
wanted me supported we all wanted each
other supported and it extends beyond
that it's you know my mama and daddy
you're a mama you're like there's like
family all of a sudden really grew
um there was tones family your family my
family and all these humans coming
together in the name of bringing this
little one into existence that was
extraordinary to me and then you know
for any of you who have been out there
and you know have miscarried and and
lost a child
um you know that was it was over a
20-year journey and it was
um painful and it was beautiful and it
was uh you know I never imagined being
here today certainly at a much later
stage of life never am I wildest and so
to have that come to fruition in such a
holistic I'm thinking of holistic bless
you
um you know that it
it's it was it is and continues to be uh
one of the most beautiful experiences of
my life
and uh if I thought it should have
looked this way or love should have
looked this way or that way or the
family was you know just this I would
have robbed myself from this experience
this merger of of Hearts it's it's so
humbling it's so beautiful uh Billy Beck
who was just here he's the Godfather of
our of our daughter
um you know the very dear sister and
friend who is the Godmother and who
lives in Israel who lives in Israel and
I thought she was born in China yes see
the tentacles that love can Branch out
too and it and it love sees no color
love sees no religion love sees no race
love sees no age love simply loves and
uh that is love transcends all the
Illusions or delusions of what mind
tells us about what a relationship our
life is going to be and if you're simply
open and receptive enough to be amazed
and surprised and if you can extend
possibly that two or three percent
whatever you said on your you know when
you're swiping this way or you're on an
app and looking for this person to look
a certain way if you have that thought
you we can miss we can miss you never
imagine that your family or that life
would look this way that you'd be you
know what I mean I never imagined this
never in my wildest freaking dreams and
I'm humbled by it I moved by it I'm
inspired by it I'm stretched by it I'm
schooled by it
um you know uh
it's it's quite a path and love does
that I wish that people could like if
you're watching this now like pull the
scroll bar back and listen to what she
just said again because
it's like it's not and tone always says
a relationship and love is this place
that you go to give and not a place that
you go to get so if you have this
expectation that this partner of yours
is just going to meet your every need
just be open to it looking so
differently than you thought not just
your the partner that you're the how the
whole constellation I call it because
this is this is even like there's so
many pieces of this that I'm just like
even when I see friends that I haven't
seen in years and I'm like I know you're
not going to believe this but this is
what I'm doing these days like people
are like wait what now like and I just
think if you are willing to open your
heart and say I want to grow and I want
to learn and I want to just I want to be
stretched and I want to see what life
might might be out there show me
something isn't that the isn't that what
love like isn't that the fun when you
think about if you've had any experience
of like the excitement and the newness
you can have that if you take your
filters off and say I'm open to anything
I really am yes you know and then
newness can be
it can you know my mom and dad were here
a couple months ago and uh my mom and I
had a moment we were sitting at the
table and our daughter was sitting next
to us and you know she took my hand and
I can just feel my mom patting my hand
and you know just that touch that moment
you know
um lingers with me you know love uh sits
with somebody who's transitioning from
this world that's love you know love
um I mean from birth to death uh love
um
extends and you know we do it really
well as human beings well not all of us
but you know a lot of times when
children are young there's that
there's not a lot of expectation you
can't expect much from a child you know
that you know they're going to be you
don't mean they're going to do what they
do uh but you know to be able to see
what the lens of that willingness of
Purity and innocence to know that no
matter what the behavior just like you
just like you there's an innocence
inside of me there's an innocence inside
of you no matter what the behavior
and I think that that is a powerful
understanding to remember and that is
where we all meet and uh so how can I
point the finger at another I need to
point the finger back on myself because
whatever I think you should or shouldn't
be doing somewhere in the line we've all
you know we've all been unconscious
we've all missed we've all been harsh
we've all been unkind
we've all yelled we've all probably
thrown something or smashed something
you know we've all done we've all is in
this Human Experience it's like it's so
there's this weird dynamic of oh he's so
this or she's so that or can you believe
this and it's like yeah I can believe it
this Human Experience I can believe
anything if you've never walked into an
Apple store with your phone in a
thousand pieces have you ever really
been in love just me can't be
that's true but you even said like we're
good at it or we're not good at what at
love or you know
I I said that we're we're wired for it
but we're also we don't necessarily know
how to do it and you talk about there
are skills to it it is muscle and it is
something that like
what do you think I don't know if it's a
skill
well I you know I think it's more of an
art
I think it's more of uh a recognition of
an allowance of a state of being
um I think it's more of an offering
uh and that's not to say that there's
not very useful tools
um and strategies and insights it helps
us navigate one's own self never mind
another uh so there's not to say but I
don't know that that's the skill for
love I think that's the skill for
managing a human yes you don't mean
anything different okay you're right I
don't know if that I did it I don't
think love is a skill you're exactly
right I do not think love is just go but
I think like sustaining it and nurturing
it especially a relationship with
human beings
that's something that to navigate
ourselves and another we could use some
skills
so it just in an effort to provide some
practical uh little takeaways we often
are this is by this book is by Dr Julia
Caldwell a friend of ours
who we found she lives in Colorado
and she wrote a book called the
relationship skills workbook and Tony's
taught a few things at different
programs the relationship program a date
with Destiny but really simple ideas
like he teaches this process called so
sensation emotion and what you want so
just how to how to communicate with a
partner yeah you list a sensation in
your body that's an unarguable thing
nobody can argue with a sensation in
your body and then the emotion you're
feeling and she taught at one of the
conferences that you guys hosted
that there's these five primary emotions
and she said them in a rhyme like in a
mnemonic that was sad mad glad scared
excited you remembered yes no I'm
remembering that and I want to just
provide one context for the sensations
Mary said something uh really beautiful
because it's in an arguable statement uh
what that assists us to do is to drop
the blame rather than you made me feel
this way you yelled at me and I'm you
don't mean it drops that it's just I'm
feeling this sensation sorry I didn't
mean to interrupt you didn't interrupt
at all and that's exactly what you're
saying is exactly there's something in
here that's so powerful so Julie one of
the tidbits in this book is we're always
moving out our goal is always moving out
of blame and into responsibility which
is something I just like that to me is
an essential
skill like tone would say write that
down move ourselves out of blaming the
other and into responsibility of self
and so I was gonna say you know there's
all these stories when we get going
about our partner did this or they did
that or our ex whatever it is these big
long
stories when really she taught she stood
up and she taught there's only these
those five emotions and it's a it's a
really clean way to look at it and say
all right like what am I really if you
feel stuck or something like what are
you really feeling are you sad are you
mad are you glad are you excited are you
scared are you a combination of any of
those all of them maybe
and just like if you feel like in a
stalemate with someone that you love no
matter who they are a partner a mom a
friend a co-worker
come back to the simple things if you
have to like what is the emotion are you
feeling sad is there a loss are you mad
is there an anger or is it because of an
obstacle that you're facing are you
excited are you scared is there a fear
or a threat that you're facing like just
get simple with it and yes you know
simplify instead of some big long story
that takes you know 20 minutes to
explain
well that is from blame to
responsibility yes Mary and that's such
a profound tool because it drops the
narratives and the blame and the
external demonization it allows us to
take responsibility for our experience
and that's loving
it's loving to take responsibility it's
loving to drop our blames it's loving to
drop our judgments of the other uh it's
loving to know that hey you don't have
to charm me you don't have to entertain
me you can simply be who you are and I
see you
and I think that's the beautiful gift of
life that's a beautiful gift of love is
piercing that lens of you know the
projections and seeing the beautiful
kind soul that is you know behind those
layers uh perfect and whole as is as am
I as are you whoever is listening you
know that's where we all meet
I told you she ends every sentence
well I have to pay attention to that I
like it I think it's a great reminder
hmm
it is because it connects us it unites
us it aligns us it reminds us of that of
our Oneness rather than our separateness
and I find that to be a beautiful lens
and a beautiful reminder
you often offer Grace
um
before going to bed before getting in
the car by what I want to mean by that
is anytime you and I have had any kind
of disturbance
I misunderstanding misunderstanding
that's a better word for it
I tend to go to my room and think about
the misunderstanding
and inevitably this says a lot about you
Sage is I'll hear like a knock on the
door and you'll come in
and you'll be like you know I just want
to tidy something up or is there
anything you want me to understand or
you'll always seek to my parents did
this too and I'm grateful for the
example but I do think it's something
that's so important in any kind of
relationship
is before bed
before you get in your car yes just
because life is that precious
to lean in you know to lean in and to
offer because you know if you think of
love being you know attributes of it or
an expression of it is gentleness and
kindness if you weren't that the more if
I wasn't that in a moment if I was harsh
in my words or if I was short if I was
curd or
um you know and in the moment that I
come back to a Clarity of mind and heart
I want to take responsibility for that
and clear that for you and for me you
know for you and for me it feels
unpleasant to be in a state of fear to
be in a state of resistance so to come
and offer
um
kindness is not only kind to you it's
kind to me
okay
so for those of you who are listening
and life is offering us that opportunity
every moment and I pray out of you know
this entire conversation if that's if
you have one takeaway just a reminder
that your presence the reminder that
your smile the reminder that
um
your tone of voice a glance matters to
your children to your beloved to your
parents to your friends to your
co-workers uh
and um
you know
let's love this world up let's love this
world up I I trust if you're listening
that there is a longing or a yearning
inside of you
uh to express uh you know the deepest
and most sincere Part of Yourself
uh and I think life is offering us that
opportunity every moment so don't miss
that opportunity to love we don't need
an excuse we don't need a reason to love
thank you for tuning in
thank you for your Open Hearts your open
minds
and thank you for walking this path
Lucia hear from you again
summer and I love you existence yes love
you thank you
does anybody want a water a cup of
coffee a banana
I might have more than that of soup
small dog
laughs
and I share that because those of you
who are listening would you like a sip
of water because your eyes you know this
is an emotional story but I am good I
don't know if you're crying or coughing
okay please I'm sweating
sorry we had just a little tickle and a
cough Break
um
you sit here
there you go and then we know you got a
scoop toaster okay
anything what do you think
no
there we go
so you always say love is our nature and
so I've asked myself like what what does
that mean and only in having a baby
around I've seen yeah like for example
we've got this little baby that
sometimes we push around and in some
occasion she's out and we interact with
other strangers and if you can push you
out in a stroller in a stroller yeah yes
put a shirt around funny boss her around
she bosses us around let's be serious no
so um
let me try that again so
our little baby when I want one to prove
the fact that because I've asked myself
like is love human nature I believe it
is but I'm like sometimes people feel
like they have the propensity to go in
quite in different direction and then
their reaction the response to a little
baby that is elicited
universally by like you know you could
walk we have people even that we we love
and we know they're like you know this
grumpy old man out there they see this
baby and it's like
lit up with love which proves to me like
love is our nature in these right like
we are I'll go back to Tone's teaching
on love of six human needs it's love is
an absolute human need we are wired for
it it sustains our life but what is
falling in love
what is it well how do you even describe
it you know like what is this falling
you know maybe it's that we're
it's a mirrorship it's reflecting each
other as if you think of even that day
when you're talking about the hallway I
was just reflecting the beauty of who
you are and maybe in that moment you
forgot and I think that that's what love
does you know if our if our our daughter
is you know having a wave of an emotion
just so it's kind to be able to just sit
down and let her experience and honor
what's coming to the surface that's kind
for each of us never mind ourselves you
know that's what love does
and I forget
I can forget and when I do I you know
I reminded I buy these amazing
incredible uh humans that are all around
us and uh you know curiosity and
interest to
um get to know another I think is is
ever so beautiful
I'm looking at you Ethan because you're
one of them
that's true see who so I would say if
you're listening like see who you can
fall in love with today not in a weird
way
but have your eyes be opened to the
folks whoever it is in your life
and you know see what's lovable
everybody's lovable co-workers yes yes
we are also in love like our team I mean
I love each and every one of them I'm so
blown away I'm so humbled I enjoy them I
enjoy their minds I enjoy what they
bring to the table
um because they're each on their path
you know doing their own inner work
taking responsibility and and offering
Grace
love does offer Grace
foreign
[Music]